Great. Now that we've got our data loaded, we're at the point where we can
start playing some sounds. [SOUND]. Let's take a look at our skeleton code for
this. We have a play sound method, that takes a path to the sound effect that
you want to play. As well as an object containing all the settings. For our
purposes, let's say that the setting's dictionary contains a bullion looping for
checking whether we want to loop an effect, and volume to set our initial gain
at. What we want you to do, is to create a source to play this sound. Connect
it to our main node, and then start playing it. Now there will be a bunch of
little things that you're going to have to keep track of here. Is the sound
manager enabled? Is the sound loaded? Or are we trying to play a null sound?
Don't worry, we're going to be giving you feedback as you submit your code, and
which possibilities you haven't taken into account yet.